[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
stretching the limits of microscopy
imaging with deep learning
i am kayli bach of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinths and brought to
you by leica microsystems
to learn more visit
leicamicrosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
hoyan lai
content marketing manager and senior
application specialist for avia at leica
microsystems
hoyan you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone welcome to the second
webinar in our series in ai microscopy
my name is hoyan i'm the senior
application specialist with the avia
team here at leica today we'll talk
about ways to stretch the limits of
microscopy imaging using deep learning
let's go over today's agenda first we'll
cover examples of a deep learning
workflow for gentle long-term lifestyle
imaging next we'll talk about how deep
learning training works in the realm of
image processing then we'll cover the
best practices for gathering training
data so they can start training a deep
learning model on your own and finally
we'll wrap up with a question and answer
session you can enter your questions in
the comments window and we'll go over
your questions at the end of the
presentation
when we run long-term live cell imaging
experiments the most important aspect is
to keep the sample alive and from the
data analysis perspective the spatial
resolution and the temporal resolution
are quite important if we want to see
certain rare events or interactions
ideally if you can optimize the spatial
and res temporal resolution on the
microscope we will be able to get the
optimal data analysis data possible for
analysis
but in reality we would also have to
take into account the sample viability
to make sure that the acquisition
settings that we are using are not going
to cause the sample to become unbiable
with deep learning we could stretch the
limits imposed by these three factors
and get high quality data for long-term
imaging without affecting the sample
viability
so here's a couple of examples there
have been many developments that uses
deep learning to improve and restore
microsd images
this is not an exhaustive list of
applications that are enabled by deep
learning these are just the examples
that are relevant to long-term lifestyle
imaging
let's take a look at
the image on the left side so this is
about the convolution
deconvolution is a computationally
intensive process that requires
specialized knowledge to recover the
original image signal with deep learning
you can have the computer figure out the
optical parameters and the optical and
the image distortion profiles are needed
to apply the deconvolution
and when we look at this image on the
left we have a neuron sample that is
imaged on a resonant scanning confocal
system that
at a very high acquisition rate and with
the deconvolution deep learning model we
can reconstruct the image and improve
the image quality so if we see
the image on the left it is split
between on the two sides the left is the
resident confocal and on the right is
the deep learning restored image
if we look at the image in the middle
this is about denoising denoising is
another process for improving the image
quality by removing noise on the image
and enhancing the contrast between the
foreground and the background and
looking at the left side of this image
we have a noisy image that is very um
that is acquired with very low light uh
exposure and with a deep learning model
we can recover the image signal using it
and you can see that on the on the right
and you can see
the collagen matrix that is in magenta
is much cleaner in this case
and beyond improving the quality of the
existing data you can also use deep
learning to enhance the spatial
resolution of the image as you can see
on the right on the image on the right
hand side
here the deep learning model generates a
super resolution version of the convocal
image that is on the left side of the
split
the resolution of the nuclear pore
complexes in green and microtubules and
magenta are improved to a level that is
comparable to that of stat on this image
another super resolution example that
i'm going to cover later in this
presentation is going to use deep
learning to simulate images from an
expansion microsd experiment
so here is an example of a deep learning
denoising model in action
so this is a fixed sample of tom 20
labeled mitochondria that are captured
on an isom system on the left side you
have the raw image which is acquired on
very low laser power and you can see
that the mitochondria and the background
it diff is not very different in in
appearance
and on the right hand side you have the
ground troop image which is acquired on
high laser power and it's been
deconvolved to get the best possible
image
for the uh
for uh the training the deep learning
model
and when we train the deep line model
using the raw and the ground tube data
we generate a model that we apply to the
raw image and you can see the result
of the model output in the middle
the label targets the mitochondrial
membrane and you can see that the
membrane is recovered in the model
output and i'm going to play this video
right now
so you can see
that
with the deep learning output the
background is much uh is suppressed
compared to the raw image and we can
also make out much of the details from
the of the mitochondria as well on this
data set
so let's extend this to a live imaging
application so we have a u-2 os
cell with mitochondria in green
and lysosome their magenta
imaging mitochondria alive can be a bit
tricky because they're very sensitive to
phototoxicity and you will need much
lower light exposure if you want to run
a long-term imaging experiments
observing them but doing that you're
going to get images that are much lower
in quality and it's going to make the
interactions between the mitochondria
and the lysosome very difficult to see
with deep learning we can recover much
of the signal from the raw image
if we look at the normalized intensity
profile
you can see a steep intensity drop-off
in the raw image in the cyan as we
acquire more image volumes but with deep
learning which you can see in the arcane
or the orange line the intensity is
relatively consistent with uh throughout
the imaging and that allows us to
observe the interaction between the
mitochondria and the lysosome as well as
do additional image analysis on this
so look at the video on the left you can
see the between the raw and the arc and
the noise image is that we can see much
more detail with the arcane restoration
and and that would allow us to again
observe the interaction between the
mitochondria and the lysosomes
let's take a look at another example so
we have a labeled microtubule in a
gercat t cell that has been activated by
a anti-cd3 antibody that's on the glass
slide and what we want to observe here
is the interaction between the
microtubule and the adhesion of
the cell onto the glass slide
and if we want to look at these
microtubules in
in detail we're going to need high
resolution data so one way to get the
higher resolution data is to use
expansion microspeed to physically
increase the size of the sample so then
that way we can look at the
inter um the details between
uh different
objects within the cell
within the cell
or within the sample
but once you have
expanded the sample and it's also no
longer living and that's going to make
life imaging a little bit tougher so to
that we did a two-step process to bring
expansion microscopy into a live cell
imaging with deep learning so first we
apply a denoising model to improve the
qual image quality in the time-lapse
data set and then it is followed by the
model that applies the expansion by
cross speed to the image and with this
two-step process we can image the sample
live and increase the resolution of the
data at the same time
so let me go ahead and play this uh
video this is really quick so on the top
you have the we have the isim
uh the decon isom data which um you can
see some of the microtubules that are on
this data set and at the bottom is the
output from the two step r can that we
just mentioned and you can see at the
bottom there is much more detail with
the res
on the microtubules and you can see the
interactions between the uh on the of
the microtubule with the bottom of the
uh of the glass with the glass slide at
the bottom of the image much more
cleanly
so besides a better looking image
what else is possible well it is
possible to get better analysis as well
so i'm going to start playing this video
now and i'm going to and what this is
going to show you is an example of a way
to use the deep learning model to
enhance the resolution of the nuclear
pore complexes
so i will
use a deep learning model as input to
this uh res to this analysis workflow
that i'm using as a pre-processing step
so i can
enhance the quality of the image
next i'm going to apply this
in addition applying the deep learning
model the output of that is going to be
used for segmentation and the detection
of the individual nuclear four complexes
and you can see with that
with the deep learning model and in
combination with the analysis workflow i
can get the individual
objects and individual nuclear pore
complexes
much more effectively
and of course that could also be applied
to other application
applications as well so in this case uh
we use the deep learning model to help
us improve the axial resolution of a of
the nuclei in a developing developing
embryo so on the on the right side you
can kind of see that the
resolution of the nuclei is much better
and the result of this is much more
obvious when we
apply segmentation to it and so with the
deep with the deep learning model that
we've applied we can detect that the
cells are missing in the lower
left corner
of this embryo much more effectively and
we can also get cell shapes that are
more representative of the actual nuclei
in the embryo and we can apply this
model
to the um to a live data set that will
allow us to not just um
uh reconstruct the
uh the embryo the embryo but also track
the individual nuclei
and its development over time
now that we've covered some examples of
how deep learning works in real life
applications let's talk about the
operating principles for deep learning
so if you have attended our previous
webinar this would be a refresher for
you
in traditional analysis rules are
created by humans and the data is put
through a program and we will get the
answers out of it
in ai framework the concept is flipped
on the set we can provide the data and
the answer in the form of ground truth
and the framework will come up with the
rules that maps the input data to the
answer and when we get new data we can
apply the rules are generated from the
framework to produce the answers that we
were looking for
there are many types of deep learning
algorithm so today i would like to focus
on one specific type called a
convolutional neural network
it is commonly used in image
classification applications so for
example networks like unet and arcan
uses this framework to create deep
learning models i won't go into many
details about how each of these networks
behave but generally speaking in a
convolutional neural network the input
image is sampled into smaller blocks and
each block passes through multiple
convolution layers to generate feature
maps which are abstractions of the image
that corresponds to a certain shape or
features
and some features can be prominently
represented in the data and those will
have a greater weight and in the
learning process the weights given to
each feature block are iteratively
changed until the input matches with the
output so let's say i have
up here we have an example of a picture
of a robot when we apply when it goes
through a convolutional neural network
it is going to be sampled into multiple
different blocks and each of these
blocks could be a feature map that is
abstracted from the image so for example
it could be one of the features that
could be generated
could be the segmented appearance of the
robot's arms and so and
another one could be the flat surfaces
that represents the robot's face and
feet so these could be some examples of
feature maps and these feature maps
could also be processed further and
subdivided and generate additional uh
feature maps and so on and so forth for
multiple uh through multiple layers so
in each of these layers all of the
information
from
uh from each of these feature maps
connects the um the input directly to
the output
and that's how a convolutional neural
network uh works on on principle but how
does it work in real life so let me give
you a quick example
so
um i'm going to show you the training
process in avia but you have other tools
are available that you can train the
models just the same so you start by
specifying the training data and you'll
need two sets of data the raw image and
the corresponding ground truth
next we specify the network that you
want to use and you can tune the
hyperparameter to adjust how the system
learns then when you start the training
process
the computer will handle the rest and
give you a model output that you can use
on other data sets
so let's take a look at what happens
during the learning process in a
convolutional neural network the input
image so that would be what's on the
left side of this
network chart
it will pass through the network to come
up with a prediction output image which
is represented by the crystal ball on
the right
then when you look at the prediction it
will be compared against the ground
truth
and the difference between the two is
the uh prediction error
in red in the um in the bar chart on the
on the left here
and during this pro uh the learning
process the network will then try to
minimize the error and carry it forward
for future predictions and there are two
key concepts that drive this process
called gradient descent and back
propagation
so what is gradient descent so you can
imagine an error function is a landscape
with many hills and valleys and the
current error rate is a location
somewhere on this landscape
the goal is
for gradient descent is to reach the
valley or the local minimum from the
slope that you're standing on and when
you reach the bottom of the valley so
this should give you the optimal
parameter or weight that minimizes the
error between your prediction and the
ground truth data that you put in
and this process is done over many steps
and you can adjust the steps by
adjusting what's called the learn rate
which would um impact how quickly the
training process converges to a minimum
minima excuse me or if it ever does it
all
but keep that keep in mind that the
value that since we're talking about a
landscape with many hills and valley the
valley that you are in currently could
be one of many and there could be other
values that will give you an even lower
error rate and throughout this training
uh the training process
the gradient descent process is going to
be repeated multiple times and with each
iteration it is possible that you can
find a more optimal solution
and if we look at the graphic at the top
you can see the error chart can be
represented by the u-curve and the error
rate is the red bulb and the gradient
descent would try to
reach the bottom of this u-curve by um
you'll go iterating for multiple steps
and that's what great and that's
gradient designs
another key concept for learning in a
convolutional neural network setup is
back propagation this describes the
entire process for which the weights at
each layer is optimized and the way that
this works is
the model works backwards from the final
convolution layer from the output um
using gradient descent to find the
optimal weights for each element within
the layer then moving one uh step uh up
from one one layer up or one step
further away from the output towards the
input
and repeat the same process and it will
continue to repeat until you reach the
input layer
and
so as you can see on the on this image
here that we start off from the top we
start from the layer on the right hand
side and over and it will iterate
through the each one and over time
certain connections will be strengthened
another will be weakened
and so over multiple uh iterative
process
of
a back propagation so you will the
layers and connections are going to be
continuously strengthened or weakened uh
depending on the error output and what
you will get in the final pro uh product
is a model that encodes the different
weights and filters that transform the
input image to the desired output
now that we've covered the principle of
how
deep learning works let's talk about how
to gather data to train the model i've
put together a couple of best practices
to help you get started
there are many types of network that
have different training data
requirements today i want to focus on
gathering data for training a
convolutional neural network like a unit
or rcam for this type of network you
will need a paired image of raw data and
ground truths
the raw data is your standard imaging
protocol so it can be tuned to minimize
the damage to the specimen due to light
exposure however it is recommended that
you maintain a minimum signal to noise
ratio of 3 and above and anything below
that you could see more errors from
model output
the ground truth is the optimal imaging
state for your sample meaning that it
has low noise and background signal
along with
the best resolution you can get possible
you can run the convolution to get
better quality outcomes or other methods
to our computational clearing
to improve the quality of uh of your
ground shoot data set
the image should ideally should maximize
the dynamic range and be free of any
over saturation and undesirable
artifacts or debris
so on the left side of the slide i have
uh example of what a raw and what a the
ground tree dataset looks like on the
top on the top we have the raw image
which is a quite a bit noisier and you
cannot make out as much of the
details of the mitochondria whereas as
the bottom image you uh we have the
ground troop which it has much better uh
resolution of the uh for the
mitochondria you can actually see the
membrane that up surrounds each
mitochondria and it's much has
a good dynamic contrast between the
background and foreground
and
free up any noise or debris or over
saturation
and so when you have
pairs of data that you're training with
it is important for the data to be
aligned between the raw and the ground
truth data here is an example of a model
out at the bottom you have
an example of a model output that was
trained on a confocal and set image of
nuclear pore complexes
looking at the area
where the red arrow highlights you can
see that
on the left side we have a model output
that is trained on data sets that were
not aligned and the model was not able
to resolve these three individual
nuclear pore complexes um
as well uh that you can see on in the
red arrow and then on the right side you
can see that um when we align the data
set and train and to train the model we
can actually improve the resolution and
with that we can actually see that
instead of just one blur of um
nuclear pore complexes there are three
of those items
and when you're training a model to use
on live imaging it can be a challenge to
get the image aligned and for that it is
okay to use a sample a fake sample to
image and then deploy the
model on a live data set so long as the
process of fixing the sample does not
change the sample characteristics
but if it is not possible to properly
align the data set at all then you can
also try to use simulated data uh as
well
next
train with a variety of data this is
important because it allows the model to
recognize critical features so some
examples are images of different
intensity distributions with different
shapes or sizes or with different states
so for example
let's say i'm trying to use a model to
improve the quality of
a nuclei imaging sequence
and
for tracking
nuclei depression i may also need to
include examples of when the nucleus is
going to grow in mitosis to get the
model to recognize all of these
different phases and so when i apply the
model to a light sequence which you can
see here
um
on the left
this is going to allow you to see the
chromatin condensation in the nucleus
and track the entire division process
throughout the live imaging
and one last best practice if you have a
sample of multiple features or scenes
like different organelles in a cell it
is preferred that you train separate
models for each of them as this was
would help you get the optimal output
from your deep learning models
so let's take a look at the example on
the left side here so the image on the
left is processed with a generic model
that is trained on the red the green and
the magenta channels on the features
that you see
on this image
and on the right it is processed with a
model that is trained for each channel
separately
and if we look at just the red channel
output
you can see the specialized model
resolution is much better than the
generic model output
and in more extreme cases the model may
try to correct the data in a way that
takes away from the fidelity of the data
which you can see in the on the left
side and the at the bottom
if you look at these two images both
actually came from the same nuclear pore
complex raw image but
i used a different model
on each of them on the left side the
model that i applied was trained on the
nuclear pore complexes so and this
allows um with this model the
data actually sharpens to point like
objects
um contrast that to the right where the
model that i plot that i applied was
trained on microtubules which are longer
filamentous and when the model sees
these point objects in the raw image it
tries to stretch them out like filaments
and you can see there's uh
some uh small con connectivity between
some of these points that should not
have existed that is not good
and um what are some examples of data
that you should train separate models so
for example you have uh if you're using
different imaging modalities or
acquisition settings like magnification
or exposure
objects that are of different shape
profiles so let's say you're both spots
and
filaments
or stains that targets different parts
of the same object
so um like say if you have a membrane
stain and a lumen stain um and what i'd
like to point out when i talk um between
the difference between this slide and
the previous slide is that in this case
we want to train um separate models when
uh
we want to train separate models
and not blend the data sets from
different sample classes together
so let's say if you have a raw data set
for a wide field image and a ground
truth data set for confocal you can use
you can still train the model to
transform the wide field images to
confocal but let's say if you have a raw
data set that have both wide field and
confocal images in it and a ground trip
data set uh for something like usted
you are going to likely get bad outcomes
from training because the wide field and
the confocal images look quite different
and the model may not be capable of
identifying unique features that would
allow it to um
to enhance
the
objects that you're interested in
interested in to the um to the ground
truth data
that you're looking at
so to summarize here are the best
practices for gathering training data
for deep learning model training
number one
pair raw data that are required using
your standard protocol that is tuned to
reduce damage to the sample with ground
choose that optimizes image quality
two
align the raw images and your ground
trigger images
three train with a variety of data that
represents the different states the
samples could be in
and finally separate different object
classes and train separate models for
each class to get the best deep learning
model output
and if you're curious about the
applications that i have shown on this
webinar you can go to avia-software.com
demo to request a free trial of the
software
and with that i would like to thank
everyone for your attention and move on
to the q a session thank you very much
thank you hoyan for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started
our first question asks
what is the difference between machine
learning and deep learning
all right yeah so there is uh so we
we've been hearing a lot about both of
these terms so machine learning and deep
learning so um in and they're both
belong to you know a general concept
with uh of ai so the difference between
machine learning and deep learning is
that in machine learning
you provide a couple of examples and it
works on smaller scale images uh smaller
scale data sets so it has it involves
having the human um
being there um to making sure that
identifying the features that they they
would like and then it runs through like
a specific set of operations um to come
up with the rules and then in deep
learning rather than the human actually
providing anything any information about
what they're looking for you just
provide the info you just prov um excuse
me in the in the
in the sense of the um what we are doing
with the with uh imaging is that you
provide the the raw data and the ground
truth and the and in deep learning the
software will attempt to find an answer
and correlate them and it uses a
significantly deeper network and it also
generates a lot more parameters than
this humanly possible and that allows
you to and that allows us to crea
create a rule that is more robust
compared to machine learning
great thank you
our next question here asks what kind of
system do i need to train a deep
learning model
uh yeah so um you will so and for deep
learning models so typically what you
will need is a um gp uh gpu a modern gpu
that is capable of running deep learning
so
uh most commonly used ones are the ones
that are made by nvidia but you know
there are other
hardware that are capable of doing
running machines during machine learning
as well but in the context of um the
software that i presented avia we use a
nvidia gpu um that is cuda capable
great thank you
another question here can i apply a
trained model to multiple images
yes so with a deep learning model um
it's similar to machine learning model
is that you can apply this to multiple
images and it also because the rules are
more robust uh
relatively speaking you can also apply
it to data sets that have um slightly
that look slightly different and perhaps
in some cases it might be able to even
identify things that um
that it maybe has not even seen so
that's uh so that's a really powerful
aspect of deep learning is that you
don't have to come up with the rules and
you don't have to come up with the
analysis protocol for each data set that
you're working with then the model will
attempt to do all of that for you and it
can apply to a much larger scale than is
possible
all right in our next question here how
do you align your images
um so how so there so how we do it is we
have an in-house script that um uses um
that
shifts the pixels so um that shifts the
image pixel by pixel to find the matches
but there are other ways um i know
there's some tools that are in image j
or in fiji that are available for doing
the alignment and in other cases for our
ground troop data we also use the same
system as well so
for instance for the
when we were training the confocal to
set model we were using a system that
was capable of imaging in the confocal
mode and then also in the stead mode so
then that way the sample is fixed
on the
on the stage of the system and that
allows us to image them both at the
exact same time
so that would be so so i would so if
we're doing um image alignment that
would be the most recommended way to do
it yeah
great thank you
all right well we'll go ahead and wrap
up with that final question there and i
want to thank you again hoyen for your
time today and your important research
we'd also like to thank labrits and our
sponsor leica microsystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone goodbye
you